marqué par la catastrophe ils redoutent
encore le pire
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont pas
partis à caux qui est attendre la suite
qui attendent après élection qui
s'interrogent sérieusement s'ils vont
continuer à bbc s'ils sont pas plus
protectrice au jeu dangereux qui nous
menacent leur mettrais nous chercher
l'usure la voie ferrée est loin d'être
en parfait état rails et traverses
endommagés sans compter les clous qui
ment et encore des produits dangereux
il passe quatre cinq fois par semaine
sur cette voie ici des convois de gaz
propane
deux ans plus tard en pleine campagne
électorale lac-mégantic cherche à se
faire entendre
aux traumatismes subis s'ajoutent
frustration et déception pour la
population le grand enjeu électoral ici
c'est la voie de contournement faut
qu'ils me disent on va vous la
construire votre voie de contournement
qui pendant dix ans dans 2 3 1 boîte
fait soixante d'années quand vient le
passage des wagons pétrole doit
reprendre dans quelques mois
mais en attendant à chaque jour la
proximité des convois est un rappel de
la catastrophe à quelques pas de chez
lui pierre la tyrie plus cherchent à
comprendre lui été dévasté
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas ça de ma peau
après quatre semaines de campagne
électorale fédérale
inquiétant pour l'instant c'est sur la
pointe des pieds que les candidats
passent à lac mégantic et même leurs
pancartes sont moins nombreuses que
celles des maisons avant la crainte que
j'ai que plusieurs de la population
roger cantin complaisent dans l'oubli et
servira pas grand chose à faire
alors ce qu'on soit reste un engagement
plus ferme des participe au lycée
des rares circonscription aux détenus au
québec par les conservateurs seul le npd
s'est engagé à réaliser la voie de
contournement dont le coût très
approximatif aussi entre 50 et 100 75
millions $
je pense que les gens soient pas fou
mais garantit qu ils vont voter pour le
candidat pour le parti qui vont prendre
l'engagement clair par rapport à
proprement
c'est vital pour la réparation morale
mentale psychologie la population près
de 1000 personnes ont déjà quitté la
ville depuis la tragédie
mais les 5000 qui reste sentent que leur
vote pourrait avoir un impact sur leur
destinée
ici marc godbout radio canada lac
mégantic